c'est encore l'été pour quelques
semaines mais c'est quand même bientôt
la rentrée
la longueur des journées est toujours
inversement proportionnelle à celle de
nos vêtements et le soleil invite plus
que jamais aux apéros arabe
il est encore temps pour un amour de
vacances
vous savez une histoire sans lendemain à
laquelle on repense les yeux pleins de
chagrin sans lendemain des fois
l'histoire peut se prolonger un peu
l'été c'est la fête y compris pour les
bts qu'elles sont vraiment dangereux
comment les éviter que faire si on est
piqué la réponse à toutes ces questions
avec des thés ses partenaires de votre
épée et oui c'est moche mais bon un
temps savait depuis le début que ça
allait arriver
l'été touche à sa fin alors c'est
l'heure du bilan
chaleur humidité contrées plus ou moins
lointaines
l'été c'est le moment idéal pour choper
un parasite
alors qu'est-ce que vous avez ramené
comme souvenir quels nouveaux petits
locataires vous hébergez vous vous
souvenez il ya deux ans à peu près à la
même période je vous avais parlé du
ténia du renard mais si vous savez ce
petit animal sympathique qu'on chope en
mangeant des murs avec du caca de renard
dessus et qui pond ses oeufs dans notre
foi eh bien figurez vous que ça n'est
pas le seul parasites que vous pouvez
ramener de valence ont fait un petit
tour d'horizon ça vous dit alors bon le
ténia c'est un verre mais c'est pas le
seul
il y en a une multitude les verts ils
sont pleins et pas qu'à moitié
ils peuvent être plat rond segmenté non
segmenté il y en a pour tous les goûts
on va pas se mentir on a une grande
partie qui se retrouvent dans notre tube
digestif en général et dans notre
intestin en particulier dans l'immense
majorité des cas ces bestioles et se
retrouve là parce que d'une manière ou
d'une autre on les a avalés dans un truc
souillés par des matières fécales bon
appelons un chat un chat
alors pour nuancer un petit peu ses
propos ce qui peut être souillée
effectivement c'est des aliments mais ça
peut aussi être de l'eau ou juste un peu
touché par des mains sales et con
or dans notre bouche ça ouvre un champ
des possibles quasi pour prendre un
exemple on peut citer la sq harris alors
lascaris c'est un verre qui ressemble
comme deux gouttes d'eau à un lombric un
ver de terre quoi et qu'on avale en
bouffant ce2 la façon dont convient de
parler bon alors au début c'est tout
petit mais ça peut atteindre jusqu'à 20
cm quand même alors s'il y en a deux ou
trois ça va rêver mais ça va par contre
il peut arriver comme on en est vraiment
plein le bide ça donne faim mais c'est
pas des nouilles sautées et en plus les
larves peuvent migrer jusqu'aux poumons
ou jusqu'à la trachée vous laisse
imaginer l'ambiance le nom wii donc du
coup vous avez compris les verts il ne
se soit pas uniquement le tube digestif
y en a même qui peuvent se retrouver
dans votre système lymphatique
comme dans le cas de la filariose
lymphatique qu'on appelle aussi
éléphantiasis parce qu'elle peut
provoquer l'augmentation anormale du
volume de certaines parties du corps et
la ligue beaucoup plus grosse cloche est
alors je vous vois venir mais non le pas
que ça qu'on parle en plus c'est
douloureux et c'est handicapant aussi
bien physiquement que socialement là
pour le coup c'est un moustique qui vous
refile les larves en vous piquant et les
verts se développe dans les vaisseaux
lymphatiques ce qui provoque un
lymphoedème c'est à dire une
accumulation de liquide lymphatique de
l'info
quoique si vous voulez donc ça gonfle il
ya aussi des verts qu'on n'avale pas et
qui nous sont pas à injecter par un
moustique qui nous piquent
mais qu'ils se débrouillent pour rentrer
tout seul par les pieds par exemple si
on marche pieds nus l'enclos ce tome par
exemple il est capable de faire ça alors
on le trouve
devinez où dans le caca des animaux et
si vous n'en avez pas vous allez
peut-être marcher dedans c'est une
marcher pieds nus mais pour le coup ça
vous portera très peu bonheur c'est un
verre qui est capable de perforer la
peau et de s'installer dans vos pieds
pour donner ce qu'on appelle de façon
très imagée une dermatite vers mineuse
rampante ou la rva migrance ça donne des
choses comme ça par exemple alors la
bonne nouvelle c'est que la bestiole
elle peut pas faire grand chose quand
elle est à l'intérieur
un genre elle peut pas se reproduire on
dit qu'elle est en impasse parasitaire
parce que c'est parce est allé dans le
bon animal à les coincer est là et elle
peut rien faire parce qu'il faut quand
même la faire sortir parce que ça pique
autre revers autres lieux de
villégiature le toc socar haqqanis que
présent chez les chiens et le toque
socar à cathy qui est présent chez les
chats peuvent contaminer l'être humain
la plupart du temps c'est pas bien
méchant sauf sauf s'il décide de
s'installer dans vos yeux
parce qu'avoir un verre à l'oeil
si ces genres l'happy hour c'est cool là
c'est tout de suite moins festif ça
s'appelle une toxocarose oculaire et la
plupart du temps ça soigne juste avec
des médicaments
par contre attention c'est vrai qu'on le
rencontre plus facilement sous les
tropiques mais on peut aussi attrapé ça
en zone industrialisée donc éviter de
jouer avec des crottes de chiens ou des
crottes de chat de manière générale
évitez de jouer avec des crottes pour
vous amuser vous pouvez vous baigner par
exemple ces lieux wayne on attendait
pardon alors par dans l'eau douce par
contre dans l'eau douce stagnante
il peut y avoir tout un tas de trucs
aussi jean py schiste aux hommes par
exemple alors les schistes aux hommes
c'est des verres plats il se développe
dans des mollusques jusqu'au moment où
ils sont assez grands pour vip lors du
tout ça et quand ils sont assez grands
pour vivre leur vie tout seul ce qu'ils
peuvent faire par exemple c'est pénétrer
à travers la peau d'un être humain et se
retrouver dans le foie le système
digestif la vessie ou les vaisseaux
sanguins
donc là aussi ça se soigne mais ça fait
pas envie quand même alors oui toujours
au rayon baignade
disons que les verts c'est dégueu mais
c'est tout petit fille alors que le
poisson penny
alors donc c'est vrai il s'appelle pas
vraiment poisson pénis on l'appelle
plutôt le poisson vampire du brésil ce
qui n'est pas beaucoup mieux mais son
vrai nom c'est quand dilou c'est mignon
alors qu'en fait c'est une petite bête
de maximum une quinzaine de centimètres
et qui a la particularité de rentrer
dans les branchies des poissons chats
dans le fleuve amazone puisque c'est là
qu'ils vivent puis de déployer des pics
pour bien se caler à l'intérieur et de
tout bouffer là dedans bon alors vous
allez me dire oui ben je sais pas vous
mais moi mon pénis c'est pas un poisson
il a même pas de gros si donc bike
alors oui effectivement votre pénis
n'est sans doute pas un poisson chat
le problème c'est que parfois le camp de
dire où est pas tout à fait d'accord
avec vous en tout cas il n'est pas très
regardant sur la gueule du poisson chat
dans lequel il a envie de rentrer donc
il peut lui arriver de pénétrer non pas
dans un branchies mais dans un mur être
on raconte qu'il remonterait le flot du
rin pour trouver la porte d'entrée
mais ça c'est un petit peu sujets à
caution parce qu'a priori ils repèrent
plus tôt ses proies visuellement
bon je sais pas vous mais moi en tout
cas si un jour je dois piquer une tête
dans l'amazone
je pense que je passerai quand même
autre notamment des mauvaises rencontres
évidemment vous posez en faire pendant
les vacances à la même plein d'autres
parce que là je sais pas tout citer
vous avez compris que celles ci on les
attrape plutôt dans les zones tropicales
donc petit conseil si vous vous rendez
dans ces coins du globe globalement
éviter de boire ou de manger des trucs
plein de kaka pour ça je vous renvoie
vers ma vidéo sur la turista les
conseils sont exactement les mêmes
évidemment lavez vous les mains après
avoir été aux toilettes ou après avoir
touché des trucs et prêcher la bonne
parole autour de vous au maximum ne vous
prendre des papiers nu et compris
pourquoi qui vous pouvez évitez de vous
baigner en eau douce c'est mieux bah je
voulais donner un ou deux exemples mais
il y en a plein d'autres
et puis pis c'est pas dans l'eau en
france elle est bien sûr quand vous êtes
rentrée allez voir votre médecin si vous
sentez qu'il ya quelque chose qui ne va
pas ou si vous avez eu un problème
pendant vos vacances sans avoir la
possibilité de consulter si tout va bien
c'est pas la peine d'aller voir votre
médecin comme ça je sais ça a l'air va
laissant dire comme ça mais il ya quand
même des spécialistes qui se sont posé
la question est ce qu'on fait un bilan
systématique quand on revient des
tropiques
c'est un petit peu controversé mais a
priori un bilan systématique ça sert à
ne plus coter parent
profitez de vos vacances sous les
tropiques ou ailleurs avec ses petits
conseils vous devriez pouvoir éviter les
bronzes on voit la dtcc fini pour
aujourd'hui
profitez bien de votre été on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos
d'ici là prenez soin de vous et prenez
soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout porteuse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]